el salvador the very first country in
the world to make bitcoin legal tender
is issuing a bitcoin bond and they are
heavily over-subscribed according to
reports there's a billion-dollar bitcoin
bond also known as the volcano bonds
that's going to be issued by the country
and they now reportedly have over 1.5
billion dollars of demand now the
context here is really important to
understand previously buchelli the
president of el salvador went to the imf
and said we need an emergency 1.3
billion dollar credit line to fund our
budget with 2021 revenue shortfall
amounting to nearly 6
of its economy the imf said that el
salvador's adoption of bitcoin entails
considerable risk to the country's
financial stability
and consumer protection on top of that
el salvador plans to offer investors a
10-year bond at an initial 6.5 percent
coupon roughly half what the country
would otherwise need to pay to raise
such capital and so ultimately what
we're watching play out here is a
country went to the imf they went to the
legacy system they said we need a loan
and they got their hands slapped they
said we don't like your whole thing with
bitcoin and so now el salvador says
screw it we're going to go directly to
the people we're going to issue that
billion dollar bitcoin-backed bond and
we're going to use half of the proceeds
to actually purchase bitcoin the other
half we're going to use to invest in
infrastructure and it looks like the
people around the world are stepping up
over 1.5 billion dollars in interest
already now we've got this quote right
here from samson mal the former chief
strategy officer at blockstream which
says that pension funds and
institutional money will come later
everyone's watching to see how the first
volcano bond goes now of course all eyes
are on el salvador all eyes are on these
bitcoin bonds but the president of el
salvador has continued to [ __ ] post on
twitter he continues to call out all of
the hypocrisy that's playing out when i
tweeted back on february 1st that the
u.s debt had officially crossed over 30
trillion dollars he said el salvador
debt is on an unsustainable path though
right and then he went on to tweet again
after the most ridiculous tweet around
inflation from bloomberg over the
weekend and he said the most powerful
country in the world is falling so fast
that it makes you rethink what are the
real reasons something so big and
powerful can't be destroyed so quickly
unless the enemy comes from within now
the hard truth is that all of these
little [ __ ] posts all these little data
points they have a hint of truth in them
and that's why it pisses off people in
the united states and abroad ultimately
el salvador is plugging their country in
to the bitcoin standard the volcano bond
that bitcoin-backed bond is going to be
a milestone in sovereign debt if they
raise all billion dollars in seconds the
world's going to take notice and many
other countries will follow hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time